Hello, everybody! That's Malia...
...our technical advisor.
It is wonderful to see all of you today.
Welcome! I hope everybody had a wonderful Easter.
This is one of the greatest White House traditions because it,...
...it reminds us that this is the people's house.
And to see so many children out here...
...having a great time...
...just fills Michelle and myself, and the entire family with a whole lot of joy.
So, I'm not really in charge here today.
My sole job,...
...in addition to thanking Fergie for that wonderful rendition of our national anthem, and...
...thanking my buddy the Easter Bunny for being here,...
...is to introduce...
...my First Lady, your First Lady, Michelle Obama.
Alright! Okay, it's working.
Welcome, everybody.
I have... I don't have much to say. I want to welcome you all to the 2009 White House...
...Easter Egg Hunt. Yay!
Our goal today is just to have fun.
We want to focus on activity, healthy eating.
We've got yoga. We've got dancing. We've got storytelling. We've got...
...Easter egg decorating. Oh! We've got basketball.
A little soccer, as well. And we want everybody to think about moving their bodies,...
...get out. We don't have tennis. It's on the tennis court,...
...the peanut gallery back here.
So, the goal today is to have fun, to get out and play.
And let's get things started with the Easter Egg Roll. Thank you all for coming today.
Have fun. Thanks so much.